let's get a bit more analysis on what is
happening in Ukraine join me now is
Stuart Ray former warrant officer in the
British Army intelligence Corps and now
a senior Analyst at McKenzie
intelligence Services Stu thanks for
coming in
um Dominic talking there about uh as a
style specifically but also what's
happening with the Russian forces now
we've seen in the last few weeks that
the area that Russia controls slightly
shrinking what do you make of that and
what we're seeing here is a refocus and
redeployment of the efforts that we're
seeing in in the particularly around the
Khaki region there have been reports
that the Ukrainian forces have now
pushed the Russians to the East and to
the north of kharkiv and even reports
that some of the the Russian forces have
been pushed back over to the border and
the ukrainians are at that border just
to the north of of kharkiv what we we
have in this area coming down from belgo
Rod which is a vital strategic Supply
like a logistical Hub over in the
Russian border are key lines of
communication or supply lines supporting
the the Frontline forces in the care of
Islam and severodonesque these are
strategically important to ensure that
the Russians can continue their fight on
the front line the loss of these vital
supply lines in that area coming down
from Belgrade would be a severe
strategic impact or a blow to the
Russian forces on the front line and
it's key that they keep those supply
lines secure keep the ukrainians out of
range of rocket and artillery fire and
that's why blue we're seeing is the
Russians just refocusing their efforts
and redeploy our forces to secure their
ensure they're securing those vital
supply lines and what about what is
happening in maripole itself and at the
steel works there um that's very
interesting we've seen the reports of
the the evacuation of the Indian
soldiers they're now being treated we
believe in Russian territory or Russian
held territory we've also seen some
unconfirmed reports that some of the the
soldiers the able-bodied soldiers are
also being evacuated from there to be
held in detention centers most likely to
be used in a prisoner of war Exchange in
in the very near future but what that
does know that's the that's basically
the the end of the last Enclave of
resistance that the Russian forces were
were encountering in that southern
access uh Southern axis so they now have
secured the land bridge the vital
strategic land bridge from Russia down
to the Crimea then I control all the
ports in the sea of azov and it's it's a
vital victory that the Kremlin can now
present to its people that it's it's
winning the war in this area I mean and
what do you think that the knock-on
effect will be in terms of the war and
in terms of Russia movements now that
they've managed to achieve that Linker
well they've now um secured that area
there the forces are now freed up but
what we've got to remember is the forces
that we're fighting in that area they're
going to be
um tired and weary from from some
constant fighting in an area and there
is a potential for them to be redeployed
to focus on their efforts maybe the push
north towards Donetsk to secure the
donbass region or possibly just to learn
to help subdue the population clearly
there are some problems with them
subduing the population the Kirsten area
um who are you know resisting the the
Russian occupation in that area to
actually secure an area you need to have
the to subdue that population or have
the support of that population which of
course they don't have at the moment Ray
thanks very much